on september 1st 1859 a gold miner in
denver started his morning routine he
felt unusually tired but shrugged it off
as he prepared his coffee he was used to
waking up at sunrise but noticed the sky
was much brighter and redder than usual
maybe a nearby fire he wasn't sure
a few minutes later his wife came
downstairs and asked why he was up so
early confused he looked at the clock in
the wall it was 1am at the very same
moment the ship's southern cross was
sailing off the coast of south america
when suddenly the seas turned violent
waves lashed at the hull and hail
pounded the deck the water reflecting
the red sky above seemed to turn to an
ocean of blood that morning an
astronomer turned his telescope toward
the sun and noticed something strange
what happened next was terrifying
let's find out why
[Music]
on september 1st astronomer richard
carrington was studying the sun when he
noticed something unusual at about 11
a.m he was observing a huge sunspot
about 10 times the size of the earth
then suddenly a flash of intense white
light burst out of the spot what
carrington didn't realize was he had
become the first eyewitness of a major
coronal mass ejection or cme and it was
headed straight for earth 17 hours later
the night sky in north america lit up
like the day aurora borealis typically
seen near the north pole were visible in
miami and cuba and as far south as
colombia in the southern hemisphere
aurora australis were visible north of
brisbane a few hours later on september
2nd the most powerful solar storm ever
recorded crashed into the earth's
atmosphere our magnetic field was
immediately overpowered and created
chaos around the world telegraph lines
were shorting out in europe and north
america equipment was throwing sparks
and some burst into flames telegraph
operators were burned or jolted with
electric shocks the word went out to
telegraph operators to shut down the
equipment they did but even disconnected
from their power supplies everything
still worked in fact telegraphs were
more powerful than ever nobody had ever
seen anything like this before this
became known as the carrington event and
at the time scientists thought this was
a unique phenomenon well was it unique
nope it's happened before it's happened
since and it will happen again and when
it does it could be the worst natural
disaster in human history
[Music]
in 1859 the connection between the sun
and the earth's magnetic field wasn't
well understood but at the same time
carrington saw the eruption the q
observatory in london reported a large
magnetic disturbance in the ionosphere
this allowed scientists to correctly
link geomagnetic storms with solar
activity like flares solar wind and
coronal mass ejections the sun's outer
atmosphere the corona is structured by
strong magnetic fields sometimes these
fields become twisted slowly building up
energy like winding a spring when these
magnetic fields finally realign that
energy is released which causes a solar
flare or an ejection
well flares and cmes can happen at the
same time but they aren't the same thing
a solar flare is basically a flash of
light they're relatively small and take
place in the lower solar atmosphere cmes
on the other hand are huge sometimes
bigger than the sun itself a cme
launches billions of tons of superheated
plasma into space at several million
miles per hour cmes happen all over the
sun's surface and most of the time they
drift harmlessly into space but
sometimes cmes come our way small ones
we don't notice on the ground we're fine
our atmosphere absorbs the cosmic
radiation and our magnetic field
deflects the sun's plasma into the poles
which fall through the atmosphere
causing auroras but just like the
earth's weather can vary from gentle to
extreme so does the weather on the sun
on average cmes happen two or three
times a day but once or twice every
hundred years the sun creates super
storms that hit the earth and when they
do the effects can range from
inconvenient to catastrophic
[Music]
there's evidence of solar super storms
going back a long time ice core samples
show powerful solar storms hit the earth
several times between 7000 and 5000 bc
in 774 a.d an extreme solar storm called
the miyake event caused the largest rise
in carbon 14 levels ever recorded in 993
a.d a storm left evidence in tree trunks
that archaeologists still use to date
ancient wood materials and this is one
of the ways they confirmed that the
norris arrived in north america 500
years before columbus 1052 1279 more
storms more spikes in carbon in 1582
1730 and 1770 solar storms caused aurora
to be seen all around the world turning
night into day and there are dozens of
reports like this throughout history but
in those reports the solar storms are
nothing more than oddities why didn't
people freak out humans don't like
chains well sure they frightened some
people who thought the world was ending
or the gods were angry but the storms
didn't cause any damage but when the
carrington event happened in 1859
civilization was doing something new we
started using machines and electricity
to operate them and that's where the
story goes from science lesson the
hollywood disaster movie a solar storm
can induce current in anything that
conducts electricity this can be the
atmosphere the ocean and even certain
types of rock though conductivity is
pretty low but electrical wires
solar storms love those and modern
civilization is absolutely covered by
and dependent on millions of miles of
wires that cover the earth a large
enough solar storm can overload power
grids destroy transformers and cause
entire grids to fail and this actually
happened in 1989 the earth was hit by a
solar storm that disrupted radio signals
across russia oh the russians had to be
annoyed oh they were at first they
thought american spies were jamming
their signals then they noticed their
satellites were unresponsive several
satellites were drifting for hours the
space shuttle discovery suffered sensor
malfunctions the toronto stock exchange
went down and suddenly millions of
people in quebec province were put in
total blackout for nine hours in 2003
another storm put millions of people in
the u.s and canada in darkness for 12
hours and the solar storms of 1989 and
2003 were a fraction of the strength of
the carrington event so what would
happen if we were hit with a storm as
strong as or stronger than the
carrington event yeah i'm guessing uh
not good
not good at all
[Music]
picture this you're on a family vacation
driving across the country to see uh
minnesota biggest ball of twine in
minnesota fine
[Music]
anyway you've got the radio on but it
starts to get staticky this is how it
begins in the ionosphere shortwave radio
has become overwhelmed with
electromagnetic interference signals
aren't getting through no vhf no uhf uhf
might be weird
you're a little obsessed yeah i'm
obsessed ship-to-shore communication is
disrupted planes using vlf signals are
knocked off course air traffic control
goes dark and planes go blind now it's a
good thing you're on a driving vacation
because airline passengers flying high
in the atmosphere just received over a
year's dose of radiation in an instant
astronauts in space receive an even
higher dose chances of developing cancer
increase tenfold as the radiation has
already begun unwinding strands of their
dna this was just the initial burst
called the precursor stage these high
energy particles move at the speed of
light so there's not much warning but a
coronal mass ejection moves a little
more slowly it hasn't hit yet the worst
is yet to come solar radiation continues
to pummel the earth the atmosphere is
saturated by high energy particles the
earth's magnetic field stretches as the
plasma tries to strip it away you look
at your dashboard your gps is acting
weird it can't orient itself then it
loses signal altogether but this is
happening to every gps system everywhere
around the world as radiation tears
through thousands of satellites in orbit
shorting out their circuits and frying
their electronics this is more than just
an inconvenient glitch affecting your
vacation global supply chains begin to
fail and within hours they will crumble
completely military communication which
relies on microwaves fails radar is
disrupted weapon systems become useless
and then
it gets worse
[Music]
by now a few hours into the event
governments are aware of what's
happening but there's no way to
communicate with the citizens all
telecommunications including emergency
services go offline back in your car
you're on a call with a friend
describing what's happening your friend
also reports weird technical issues and
mentions the stock market just went
offline but you're having trouble
hearing them your phone keeps losing the
call and as people around the world all
experience these strange events
simultaneously they saturate cell towers
but it doesn't matter nobody's phone can
get a signal not even satellite phones
work after an hour or so you start to
get concerned and decide to pull off the
highway maybe this is a good time to
fill up your tank grab lunch and try to
figure out what's happening when you
pull into the gas station the line is
already a quarter mile long
gas pumps aren't working there's chaos
because credit cards won't work atms are
offline well can i use my bitcoin nope
your crypto wallet is dark hard drives
around the world have been wiped clean
bye bye blockchain and during these last
few hours of confusion solar radiation
has continued to build in the ionosphere
the earth's magnetic field is stretched
hundreds of thousands of miles into
space and when the last of the sun's
plasma passes through the earth its
magnetic field suddenly snaps back like
a rubber band and all of that energy
built up in the ionosphere slams into
the surface at once
then things get really bad power
stations around the world are
overwhelmed the failures cascade through
every country on earth leaving entire
continents in darkness power lines and
transformers are set ablaze network
cables both above the ground and deep
under the ocean go down all at once the
entire internet goes dark now back at
the gas station someone from your family
complains that the restroom water isn't
working turns out water isn't running
anywhere pumping stations and water
treatment centers are offline you hear a
loud crash behind you there's a six-car
collision where a traffic light stopped
working looking down the street you see
that no traffic lights are working
anywhere not here not back at home not
anywhere there's no power no water no
fuel and this is just the first few
hours from here things get even worse
far worse
there have been a number of studies
outlining solar storm worst case
scenarios and each study is scarier than
the next if the carrington event or
worse something stronger happened now it
would take months or even years to get
back to normal it's been estimated that
some power grids could take up to 10
years to repair you could prioritize
water facilities hospitals and emergency
services but you'd still have millions
of people without power for months
planes would have to be grounded trains
too would have to wait some cars would
be okay but not all of them electric
cars are great but without charging
stations you'll miss that old gas
guzzler still there would be no traffic
control system now this might be okay in
rural areas but in a big city it's a
disaster one study warned about how the
destruction of the supply chain and lack
of refrigeration would cause worldwide
food riots no heat no air conditioning
no sewage disposal banking transactions
require power network access and
satellite uplink without these the
global financial system would be in
ruins right now there are over nineteen
000 satellites orbiting the earth and
many of those would be adrift solar
storms cause what's known as satellite
drag and this is where the earth's
atmosphere expands and starts tugging on
low orbiting objects if we can't restore
power to those they would start falling
back down to the earth one by one but a
strong enough storm would burn out of
satellite circuit boards so there's no
way to save it according to another
study a severe enough solar storm would
cause a complete breakdown of society
most governments would have to impose
martial law immediately and many
governments would simply collapse
remember those warnings of 2012 oh yeah
the world was supposed well in july
it almost did
[Music]
in july 2012 the largest cma in a
century missed the earth by nine days
that was the luckiest thing to happen to
our species in hundreds of years if that
solar storm hit us a quarter of the
earth's population could have been
without power for weeks
160 million americans would be in the
dark for months we would still be
recovering from the aftermath today
damage in the u.s alone would have cost
trillions of dollars and that storm
happened in the middle of summer how
many thousands of people would die
around the world without heat for an
entire winter nine days that's all that
stood between us and an instant 200 year
thrust backward in technology that would
have changed all of our lives
we had the good news part of the video
yet this is getting stressful well
nasa's solar terrestrial relations
observatory spacecraft called stereo
launched in 2006 and it can spot a cme
almost immediately
but oh no but the stereo spacecraft
can't determine the cme's magnetic field
turns out that's a key piece of data if
the cme's magnetic field is aligned with
the earth's it just bounces off magnets
repel when their poles are aligned but
you've heard the expression opposites
attract if the magnetic fields of the
cme and the earth are not aligned the
cme strips away our protection which
means disaster now the advanced
composition explorer sits about 900 000
miles from the earth and this satellite
can detect the cme's magnetic field
which gives us how much time to prepare
about half an hour
that's it that means we have 30 minutes
for planes to be grounded for satellites
to be put into safe mode and grids to be
powered down everyone has to go dark and
then we just wait it out and hope for
the best now on average there's a four
percent chance of a severe solar storm
in any given year and a 0.7 percent
chance of a carrington level event
but every 11 years the sun enters a
period of peak activity called a solar
maximum then the odds get much worse
well we're currently in solar cycle 25
which began in 2019 and is expected to
peak in 2025. during the solar maximum
chances of a severe solar storm go to 28
and chance of a carrington superstorm go
to four percent every year
every year a new roll of the dice and
despite the blackouts and chaos solar
storms have caused in recent years a
four percent chance is just not scary
enough for governments to take the
necessary action we need more resources
diverted to research more satellites and
a full overhaul of our power
infrastructure and those resources
aren't coming anytime soon hey didn't we
just pass a big infrastructure bill
yeah yeah i realized that was a stupid
question as i was asking it we can't
count on the government we absolutely
cannot instead we have to rely on
ourselves and our local communities just
like we do before a hurricane or a
tornado or an earthquake make sure your
family has a readiness plan maintain a
supply of food and water you need
thermal blankets camp stoves propane
heaters in case the heat goes out you
need hygiene supplies first aid kits and
a hand crank radio keep all these on
hand all the time just in case
so you say you become a prep well if
that's what you want to call it but
being over prepared is better than not
being prepared at all because it's just
a matter of time before the lights go
out and when they do there is no cavalry
coming in the end the only one looking
out for you and your family is you
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
subscribe comment like share and special
thanks to our patreon members you guys
make this possible and you're the best
until next time be safe
be kind
know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you